I was really excited to take on this  role I loved the idea that it was  something that I had never done before  and that I'm a guy that people would not  normally associate with this kind of  thing it was a huge part of the appeal  for me and I reckon part of the appeal  for them you know Marvel seems to have a  history of doing that putting people in  roles that you don't normally associate  that actor with playing he's been in  jail this is you know he's made some bad  decisions he's he's not a bad guy but  he's you know down on his luck and he's  done some things and maybe he's not  quite proud of and so it's an  interesting character to start your  story when and and yet he's a normal guy  he's not born with any kind of  superpower he is struggling and is  conflicted and I think that there are  elements to that than making very  relatable not not to mention that all he  has it just has all the love in the  world for his daughter and wants to do  right by her